the guy on the other side is a
sociopathic killer he literally says
that that's right when we go into full
summer i don't know how long it took to
do the full summary but it took a while
it seemed excruciating on our
terrorist sociopath on the other side
says that's right immediately
the ransom demand went away we went from
10 million to zero when the phone hung
up no monetary demand was ever raised
again through the course of the
kidnapping kidnapping last couple more
months the hostage
walks away he gets the opportunity
they're lacking in security he just
walks away we're flying back to the u.s
he's gone
bad guys got nothing i'm back in the
philippines about three weeks later
connect back up with the negotiator that
i was coaching he says you're not going
to believe he called me on the phone the
terrorist
what'd he say he said have you been
promoted i was going to kill the
american
you're really good at what you do they
should promote you
negotiating today we're gonna learn how
to hopefully have productive
negotiations
let's define our terms first what should
be our desired
outcome from a negotiation why are we
negotiating
uh well really your desired outcome
should be a better relationship
i mean um by definition i can explain
intellectually intellectually while
it's impossible to know what the best
outcome of the negotiation could be
you're holding information back there
holding information back
information being held back by both
sides is important
therefore not only is your information
flawed it's
flawed in important ways so the more
people get focused on an outcome the
more they have blinders on the more they
are
likely to miss a better deal
so if you're focused on a better
relationship that's going
to sort of permeate the interaction
and increase the chances that the other
side is going to
show you theirs and you'll get a better
deal
and then plus they're going to enjoy the
process and the chances that they're
going to want to do it again are much
higher
being familiar with your work it seems
like an adversarial relationship
during a negotiation is something that
you try and steer clear of as much as
possible
yeah because it's just it's just going
to um how much i could get
it's gonna harm my ability to get it
again
like an adversary relationship is gonna
sting the other side they're gonna
remember that
it's gonna discourage them from wanting
to continue to negotiate
with me that's not good for me long term
there was
goldman sachs executive a long time ago
gus levy his phrase was greedy yes
but long term greedy
that's a good way to put it i suppose as
well with the networking effect now
that everyone knows everyone it's much
easier to have free flow of information
you can't the charlatans and the
psychopaths and the con men
can't hide as much anymore yeah it's
gonna get out
um it it got out before anyway
it's but now it's just getting out
faster it gets out at hyper speed now
what do you think most people believe
about negotiating which is wrong or
ineffective you know that you got to
beat the other side
i mean we're even really careful how we
phrase it
like we never talk about the the person
across the table is the adversary we
refer to them as a counterpart
you have to say is the situation and if
you're negotiating with someone you're
both
faced with different aspects of the same
problem
which by definition is you're both going
to be better off if you collaborate now
most people you know they
and most negotiations categorize as win
lose beat the other side and that just
that just hurts people long term it just
does
who is the worst sort of person to
negotiate with then
and how can we get them involved in the
dialogue
yeah well it kind of it's it's not the
worst
person i mean it's typically what you
run into is occasional tight mismatches
create problems
then there's basically the world splits
up evenly into thirds fight flight make
friends
these are the caveman responses to
survival
this is wired into us it's baked into us
there's there's no way around it
and um you know the world we've we've
pulled
really the world and we've seen that
the world splits up evenly into thirds i
mean we've taught
for a while we were teaching negotiation
to executives from the chinese
development bank
and you know it's a it's a great culture
to have a stereotype about
whether they're very guarded or whatever
your stereotype might be about them
and we're working with these people
internally and we're seeing all three
times
so what does that mean um type mismatch
for example if you're very thoughtful
and you
like time to think which means silence
well if you're really conscious of the
relationship and the dynamic you
see silence as a way that people trigger
anger
so there's an obvious disconnect here
one person's loving the silence because
they want to think and the other person
is going like oh my god oh my god oh my
god the other person's mad
yeah yeah it and it is a comedy
sometimes
so being being aware of type mismatch at
a given moment is really
really the issue and if it splits into
thirds you don't have a lot to keep
track of
um if you're running into problems it's
probably a tightness match
how can we easily detect the type
of the person who is across the table
from us
yeah well you know um two of them are
really easy the assertive
is gonna be obvious they're gonna be
blunt they're gonna be loud
they're going to be forceful they're
going to act like time is money
you know um not taking a political
perspective on it any
in any way shape or form donald trump is
a classic example of the assertive
negotiator
blunt harsh aggressive time is money
time is of the essence you know his
leadership style and
he doesn't have time for the us congress
to make up its mining
issues in executive order times money
um that's that style uh the analytical
they're gonna seem cold and distant um
that's because they're up in their head
thinking analyzing stuff
and they're not in fact cold and distant
but again that's how they're going to
seem because they're thinking things
through
so those two types are going to be
fairly obvious they're going to be
the analytical type is going to be quite
comfortable with silence they're going
to go
silent for long periods of time on now
the one that is a little tricky is
what the accommodator the relationship
focused
really they're interaction focused even
more than the relationship they don't
really understand the difference
but they want the interaction to be
positive
now many analysts
become uh they look like accommodators
my my daughter-in-law is chief of
marketing of my company
brilliant girl she looks like an
accommodator she is bubbly
she's happy she laughs she's one of the
most pleasant people
on earth to deal with she's an analyst
deep down in her bones extremely
analytical
she's just smart enough to have seen
that people are more likely to comply
with her
if she's bubbly and and smiling and
happy
so a lot of people are convinced that
she's an accommodator she's not she's an
analyst and an analyst is an assassin i
mean she's a dangerous negotiator
but you're gonna love dealing with her
so that that's the only type that you
get fooled by because the other two
types catch on if they eventually
speed that they catch on various but
they catch on
that the relationship focused person
makes a lot of deals
and people want to deal with them over
and over again
now they're a little annoyed by this
because they're not impressed
by the deals but they do see that they
make a lot of deals
and that's why my daughter-in-law is a
great example she's like all right so
i'll make more deals if i'm pleasant
i'll be pleasant and it's justified the
means man
i i'm i'm very
i i agree i'm very very interested in
the way that negotiations work and
especially people's confidence within
negotiating
i think the way that we it's interesting
right because
sometimes um someone's interaction style
is a projection of their kind of inner
emotions
and for other people you mentioned uh
the
marketing your daughter-in-law um who is
essentially sort of almost playing a
little bit of a role
so she's able to adapt the person who
she is
during the interactions to get a better
outcome
doesn't mean completely compromising but
perhaps you know glazing over some bits
and enhancing other bits and so on and
so forth
um how can someone who maybe doesn't
feel like they have a massive amount of
confidence normally day-to-day
either in themselves and or in
negotiations what can they do to make
themselves feel
a bit more assertive and in charge when
they sit down
yeah you know um i'm gonna quote one of
my favorite actors denzel washington for
a movie called man on fire and
and and in one way another thing that
washington has played me in several
movies
you know he doesn't call he doesn't
write i don't get invited over to the
house
uh but uh and man on fire he's training
a little girl that he's guarding to be a
better swimmer and she says i'm not any
good
he says there's no such thing as good or
bad there's only trained and untrained
only trained and untrained so you don't
feel confident you just haven't got your
practice in
um same thought daniel coyle wrote a
great book called the talent code
codes uh coyle's contention is that
everything is learned
now i'm not sure that everything is
learned but he's got enough data that
backs up the fact that the vast majority
the ridiculously overwhelming skills of
people that are really good
learned it they weren't born with it
again you can become
confident with practice you can learn it
we advise small stakes negotiations for
high stakes results
you know practice a calm demeanor
when you order coffee it's practice
practice a calm demeanor
when you're talking to your your lift or
your uber driver
i mean we got no shortage of practice
one one young lady i'm i'm coaching in
some negotiations now
cousin covert and the economic switch
she's moved back into her parents house
which means
her mother is there giving her our time
every day
and she said my mother punches my
buttons and i said perfect it's practice
practice being calm with your mom if you
can't do it in the moment
the interactions or prepare for them
constantly you sit
you know you sit down in in the basement
the fully furnished basement and you
know when you go upstairs your mother's
going to punch your buttons and you just
see yourself getting mad
so just re-run it in your head and see
your yourself
if not staying calm see yourself being
silent it's practice
how you envision your performance it's
what great athletes do
you know michael jordan lebron james
they see themselves hitting the
game-winning shot
over and over and over they practice it
on on the court
you know they're out there by themselves
but they imagine being surrounded by
fans screaming for them to miss they
imagine being in a hostile environment
this is our practice
you could you that's way great athletes
become great you could do it yourself in
negotiation
the term that you've kept on using there
is calm does confidence come from being
calm um you know
you could do it either way you know you
could practice a convoys
and you know and that that's an
interesting point because if you
just practice you know what we refer to
as the late night
fm dj voice
there's a neuroscience response behind
that if you
hear my voice when i use that voice
there's a neurochemical change in your
brain
triggered by your mirror neurons which
is an automatic response it's not a
choice
and you'll start to calm the brain down
now the
great thing about that voice is when you
use it
you hear it too
which means you can force a system
override
if you're upset and you just start
talking out loud in a calm voice
your voice is going to hit your mirror
neurons and you can
force yourself to calm down the same way
that you would
trigger the reaction in the other person
so once you discover some of the system
overrides you can use them on yourself
recently had fiona murden on who's
cognitive psychologist
a new book it's called mirror thinking
which is
exclusively about the mirror system it
might be an interesting read for
yourself or you can
listen to on the episode she's
fascinating fascinating woman teaching a
lot of leaders in business and uh
yet some of the examples that she came
up with
from the mirror system are outrageous
there was a
one girl in i want to say yugoslavia
or somewhere who had parents a young
infant parents that were drinking a lot
and not caring for her and they left her
out in the cold
one night and she got taken in by a pack
of wild dogs between the age of three
and eight and at eight years old she was
finally
sort of seen by someone who then took
her back into child protective services
but by this time she was walking on all
fours she was drinking from a tap by
licking
she was unable to speak she was unable
to write she was unable to do any of
this stuff
because she had been around animals that
had done that
so the ability for us to completely
transcend what we would naturally
probably consider
our nature bipedal talking using hands
you know
like the mirror system is so pervasive
and so powerful
that it can turn a child essentially
into a you know a kind of a
mirror of a canine interesting yeah
yeah it's crazy right the way the
neurochemistry of the brain when
these things start to kick in
unbelievable um one of the things i'm
fascinated by is your strategy for
mirroring
can you take us through that and explain
why it's effective
yeah and and very much along the lines
of what we're just talking about you
know there's the mirroring
the body language and then the the
hostage negotiator's mirror puts it
slightly different spin on it
and it's it starts with repeating the
one
the last one to three words you know
three ish
could be as many no more than five uh
but one to three is the general rule of
what somebody has just said
it causes this great thought connection
in your counterparts
thinking they they go on they reword
it's actually a much better thing than
to say what did you mean by that
you know because most people when you
say to them what did you mean by that
um they're gonna repeat it the exact
same words only louder kind of like an
american
so but with the mirror
people have a tendency to reword there's
something in the message
that clicks with the other person which
tells them okay i heard your words and i
still don't understand can you give us
an example
um yeah my son and i it's one of the
negotiations in a book we're going back
and forth we're prepping for
uh some training and i asked him if we
got the notebooks ready
now the the the notebooks uh that i have
in mind
you know they kind of they kind of look
like this
you know they're just you know a
notebook
or that's the notebook that he has in
mind now what i have in mind are three
ring binders but i'm calling them
notebooks
so i say do you have the notebooks ready
now he senses there's a disconnect in
our thinking
so in order to try to clear it up he
says to me
what do you mean by notebooks and i go
no box
[Laughter]
and he says yeah but what do you mean by
notebooks and no bugs
and finally he just mirrors me he goes
notebooks
and i go yeah three ring binders
so whatever reason there's there's
something in the way the hostage
negotiator's mirror hits a brain
that gets people to reword and continue
even when they're closely guarding what
they're saying
and the first time i ever did it you
know um i
practiced it so it's a great default
tool to go to when you're at a loss for
words
and i'm in a bank robbery with hostages
talk to the bank robber
we got his van outside and i i said you
know we
we found this van outside and he says
he says we only have one vehicle and i
said you only have one vehicle
he said yeah we don't have we don't have
one vehicle
you don't have one vehicle so will you
you chase my driver away
i said we chase your driver away he goes
yeah when he saw the police he cut and
run
now what he just did was admit that
there was an accomplice that we didn't
know about
which also meant he's giving us a
witness against him
because this is a guy who could tell on
in no way shape or form is it in his
interest to tell
me about the getaway driver that got
away
but i start marrying him and this guy
was a very
control freak negotiator he was probably
he embodied all of the characteristics
of a really dangerous
business negotiator he pretended like he
was powerless
he acted like we were the problem that
he was cooperative
he did all these things that actually
kept him completely in control while
looking powerless
which meant his words were ridiculously
well selected
and so to get him to start sharing
information he had no intention of
sharing
is a great example of how how mirrors
gets information out of people
i love that is that linked to our
addiction to correction
that you talk about is it a similar
pathway that works with that yeah it's
an interesting question i think it
probably
is it has to be there has to be
something similar to it
because the compulsion to talk is just
precisely the word i was thinking that
precisely
robin drake who you may be familiar with
with i heard him on
years and years and years ago and i
remember he was the first person
before i read your book uh he taught me
about that that compulsion to correct
and
i think his example was um how he would
get
someone to give him their birthday
and he was like uh i bet that you're
you're born in september aren't you no
no november
oh yeah yeah it must be the 16th no no
the 17th and you're like
and you can feel it's it's like a
visceral response
that you want when you know when someone
says a thing
good-naturedly not accusing not saying
like i bet that you can't lift this
weight
more just you know a natural
conversation of something that's a
little bit off
this compulsion to want to correct them
is
a powerful unstoppable
yeah it's an interesting point a lot a
lot of people
and you're triggering some other
thoughts to come to mind a lot of people
outside of negotiation they
they tumble over the power of the
compulsion to correct and they're using
a lot of different ways
and nobody ever notices that's the other
thing too like when
somebody corrects you they never notice
that they've given you a bunch of
information they they their guard
never comes up which means
you know they're not going to backtrack
on you
it's um that's cool it's really cool
really really cool
can you talk about how to say no more
productively
but there has to be a point that you
reach during a negotiation
where like you you have to give a
negative answer you have to say that
that's too far or that's something that
we can't do how can we say no
more productively yeah and and and
there are a lot of negotiators that
actually out there that are going to
continue to
to pound on you until you say no not
once
but twice i mean i've run across no
shortage of hard bargaining negotiators
and their rule of thumb
is they're not going to let up
until you've said no twice so
how do you how do you say no
productively is is is a question
you know our our first way of saying no
is how am i supposed to do that
i mean it triggers so much in the other
side it's
it's it's the opening story in the book
never split the difference
and um you know really good
really bad about that being the opening
story
people get it right away i mean i got no
shortage of
people who come up and say wow how am i
supposed to do that
i've closed so many deals at my terms
oh and that's all i ever said
but the problem is that's the only thing
they ever learned so
they could be doing so much better but
they the first time they say how am i
supposed to do that i mean it's
it alters everything in the moment
because what the other side hears
when you say that is i'd love to comply
but you're giving me an impossible task
and so let's figure out a more
productive way to proceed
and that's why typically the other side
you know if they don't feel attacked
uh they feel collaborative it triggers
it triggers collaboration my son also
refers to this
phrase as forced empathy it makes them
take a look
at you involuntarily they don't they
don't do it on purpose
but they step back and they take they
say wow all right
so let me let me rethink everything even
if they come back at you
with if you want the deal you have you
have to
the point isn't the answer the point is
the thought process you put them through
and so that's why that's that's our
first way to say no
now you can you can become a little bit
more
firm each time i mean basically we you
know i teach people four ways to say no
how am i supposed to do that
i'm sorry that just doesn't work for me
i'm sorry i can't do that
and no each one is a little more
firm and the other side
feels no coming
but they don't get punched in the face
with it
yeah is that of all of the phrases that
you have in the book do you think
that's the most powerful one that
someone could sort of take today and
plug into their
negotiating yeah it's probably the
most powerful the most applicable phrase
the easiest to learn
and it just it's fun to watch it it's
fun to watch
i bet it is can you explain what
labeling is
labeling um is has to be simple
and it's elegant labeling is
self-defining
labeling an emotion or dynamic in the
moment
um doing it as a verbal observation it
seems it sounds it looks
it feels now you've got to use those
exact words
we'll run into no shortage of people
that'll say yeah yeah no
i already know how to do that and i do
it all the time
and i say well what i'm hearing is well
those aren't the same words that i just
used and it's completely
different um
so the label has got to be concise
it's a verbal observation
what it does is it puts people into
a thoughtful mode it provokes their
thoughts
and then it people have a tendency to
give you
complete direct um
downstream download of their thought
pattern
they're less guarded i could say to you
what do you think and you'll stop
and think and you'll
fully go through your brain what you
should say
and then you may or may not give me the
answer or i could say
seems like you're thinking about
something and the chances of you
starting to blurt out
what's on your mind immediately are much
higher
and there's a massive difference in the
response you want to guard it answered
you want an unvarnished answer
the label gets you an unvarnished answer
it seems to me that a lot of the tactics
that we're using here during the
conversation
is to get people out of the semantic
games
and the linguistic games and and kind of
take them
from the this level the very
superficial visceral level and kind of
take them upstairs into their brain
without insulating them like am i
in any way sort of correct here trying
to conceptualize that
yeah i know you're on a right track you
you want to find out what's in their
head
and you don't want the guard to go up um
you're triggering collaboration is what
you're doing
you know uh i was at a gathering some
people once and one of
uh a young lady came up to me and she
said your book is how to make the other
side collaborate with you whether they
like it or not
now collaboration's a good word you know
and she
she nailed it right i'm not looking for
people to cooperate
you know that's when i'm victimizing you
i'm looking for you to collaborate with
me
so that we can make something better
together
now if you don't want to collaborate
with me you know that's a defensive move
on your part you've been stung in the
past you've been you've been
cheated in the past you've been betrayed
in the past
those are nine out of 10 of the people
that don't want to collaborate
now one in 10 is trying to cheat me
and that's why they don't want to
collaborate but
the the the cutthroat negotiators have
an outsized reputation
not that many people really want to cut
you through it they may act like it
but it's principally defensive in nature
they're just trying to protect
themselves there are some people out
there that
that are trying to cut your throat
they're a minority but everybody's
scared of them
when if you if you trusted everybody
just by percentages
seventy percent of the people seventy
seventy five percent of the people that
you
encounter you'll be okay trusting them
blindly
the problem is we don't notice that
because the people that betrayed us
that sting so bad that that
experience fogs everything else
and obscures our actual view of
realities
one of the reasons why i love the phrase
fortune favors the bold
because the universe really is on our
side if you're fearless
70 70 of the time it's gonna work out
that's a great batting average you know
las vegas which is where i happen to
live
they're building casinos on 51 success
rate
imagine what you could do with 70.
we're wired evolutionarily to avoid that
multiplied by zero right you know like
it's
the anxiety effect of just
fearing the tiger in a i'm gonna guess
tigers don't live in caves
a bear in a cave or whatever some
something bad is in a cave right
avoiding that avoiding the snake behind
the bush avoiding the whatever
um it has led us it's very very it's you
know it's right back here it's right at
the top of your spine where it meets the
back of your
back of your cranium and um it's hard to
get rid of
so that makes sense and you're correct
as well
um forget the successes remember the
losses
very much is the way that a lot of
people lead their lives
there's some strong neuropsychological
uh
research that shows we're not even
pleasure seeking we're simply pain
avoiding
like as humans we don't ever it's all
versions of pleasure are simply
different gradations of a lack of pain
and when that's the case pain is as you
said remembered
so much more forcefully this
sort of leads me nicely into something
that i really love
that i've taken from your work which is
about implementation and agreement like
yes is nothing without how can you
explain
what that means yeah well
even if people mean to agree with you a
lot of people just don't think it's
wrong
so like you and i couldn't tend to have
a great
great agreement i just haven't thought
i'm going to implement it
and as soon as you start asking me how
you put me in an implementation phase
and you know uh as they say hope it's
not a strategy
we can't hope this is going to work out
we actually got to think it through
so that's the first issue with genuine
people second issue is this whole yes
thing
there's three kinds of yeses commitment
confirmation and counterfeit
now there's this nonsense out there
called the yes momentum or momentum
selling
and that is if i get you to say yes
enough times
to the little things you got to say yes
to the big one
they refer to each yes as either a micro
agreement or a tie down
just tying down each micro agreement
means they
have to say yes now everybody has been
stung by this
two or three times so
it prob you know worked on me when i was
21 and a sales person called me to tell
me about this discount coupon book that
only cost me
five dollars and i get fifteen thousand
dollars in benefit
i'm like yeah yeah i want that
you know everybody's been suckered into
this you know there's
uh you know i'm hearing things about
the timeshare profession these days you
know people buying timeshares
do you want to live in a five-star
resort
for free would you like to have a great
vacation home that paid for itself
that you could visit whenever you want
yeah and then
people find themselves in a massive
amount of debt and every time they
call to try to get out of it they find
themselves more at that
like you're going to get stung by the
yes momentum until you learn
to be suspicious of everybody trying to
get you to say yes
people are yes back the same way
children
battered children are battered by adults
every time an adult
raises their hand they think they're
going to get hit
so you might not be trying to lure
somebody
into a deal with yes but somebody else
already did
and you're like the adult who's trying
to give a child a legitimate hug
they're still gonna duck so the more you
try to get people
into yes the worse your problems are
gonna be and as soon as you shift into
how
you're out of this yes problem entirely
and you're about how do we make a great
deal how do we move forward
how do we profit then your deals
sail through in a in a much faster much
smoother way
i guess that links back to what we said
at the very beginning as well about not
just battering the other side
because if someone's agreement is
based on implementation
are more likely to have thought through
what they are agreeing to and less
likely to
uh over agree uh i guess
as in agree to something that they
didn't mean to or that later on they're
going to regret
i often use this um example so i work in
the nightlife industry
and i've stood on the front door of a
thousand different nightclubs and
watched a million drunk people go into
them
uh and a lot of the time you'll have an
event
let's say it's a really popular date
maybe halloween or new year's eve
something like that and someone comes up
and it's it's
ram to the rafters there's very very few
spaces left over and this person's
desperate to get in
all of their friends are in there all of
their all their friends have got a table
or it's a group of guys that are local
but didn't manage to get tickets or
whatever and this
it's a final table and they're
absolutely desperate to get in
and the temptation is to say
when uh demand outstrips supply what do
you do you like
throw the price through the roof so you
char you say you can come in
but it's going to be some astronomical
figure
right like some like 10 10 x what it
would be 20 x what it would be
and they might pay it so they might have
agreed to the price but they might not
be happy
about having paid that price so that's a
real key insight that i got from your
work which is
not to assume that just because someone
has agreed to the deal that it means
that they are happy about the deal
uh good point yeah exactly because
you're gonna you're gonna run into
problems on down the line
and when as soon as they get a chance to
try to get you back
they're going to get get you back with
interest
you know they're not going to try to get
even they're going to try to get way
past ethan when they get your back and
so then that
you know that's bad that's bad long term
it's a great way to put yourself
in a position where you got lots of
people who want to pay back
very much right um so going on from the
club promotion situation a lot of the
time
i will be stood next to the doorman so
we work on the front door you'll have
seen it the guys with the clipboards and
making sure that everything runs right
there's no catastrophes and a lot of the
time someone that's drunk who's inside
of the venue
will be uh in varying degrees of
delicately
brought outside they may have had a
little bit too much to drink they may
have been involved in an altercation
they may have just done
something that has warranted them their
night their night is now over
and they've been brought outside by the
door staff and then they tend to come
back
to the guys who are stood on the front
or the front doorman
and there just yapping away
why is that why have i been thrown out
this is unfair all my mates are inside
blah blah
that is a situation i must encounter
every night once a night at least
sometimes multiple times per night
sometimes it compounds and one of the
mates gets thrown out then another
friend that they were maybe even play
fighting with also gets thrown out and
then it's like a
like a compounding effect where they
both have a go
how can we de-escalate a heated to
negotiate and
negotiation let's forget the fact that
they're drunk because i'm guessing that
adds a layer of complexity that even you
can't uh get can't get us around
um but what can i what can i tell the
door stuff i work with these guys all
the night i don't want them i have to
spend their time getting abused by by
people who are a little bit unhappy what
can they do to try and
de-escalate this well um
first of all the tone of voice is
critical late night fm dj voice
you know the calming soothing voice
whatever
advantage that gives you take it i mean
many times you each individual tactic
might just be a small advantage but the
cumulative effect is what you're looking
for you're looking to score up some
points
so the calming soothing voices start
with even with drunks
that's at best not going to aggravate
the situation you know commanding voice
is an aggravating voice
it doesn't help people think so first of
all the late night fm dj boys
secondly you know repeat back to them
what they're saying a lot of times
people just want to have their say
if if all i got to
go have to do to get you to go away
is to let you feel like you've had your
say
then if i repeat it back it's clear your
point has gotten through to me
now the really the the tricky part is
is when they want to articulate negative
stuff about you
or your establishment
or you know that they
again they say they've been treated
unfairly this isn't fair
you can look at somebody and say you
feel you've been treated unfairly
and that's not agreeing it but then
people
they need if they need if satisfying the
need to be heard is enough
and now you've scored some more points
you may conclude the deal there late
night fm dj boys
make sure they know they've been hurt
particularly with the negative stuff
about you
the the the most effective way to
deactivate
negativity is to simply call it out
now sometimes you got to call it out
more than once but there's brain science
that backs this up
it's the most effective stuff you don't
want them continuing to be mad
and go away and stew on and come back
even matter
you know you want to deactivate the
negativity with the best way possible so
so let them feel like they're hurt
you're going to solve enough of your
problems just with those two things
that if there's anything that requires
any sort of an escalation
at least you didn't need to escalate
unnecessarily
yeah i like that a lot are you very very
correct as well about people just
needing to be heard
i think you can in an ideal world the
people who were rejected by the door
staff who are inside
would go that's my night over i'll i'll
head home
in that must happen one time in
50 maybe or one time one time in 30.
it's very rare
vast majority of the time when the
people all of us who are stood at the
front
see someone being brought upstairs
you'll see the promoters
who are usually dressed in like skinny
jeans and like cool shoes or whatever
we'll just part a like moses sort of
moving the red sea we'll just give the
door staff a little bit more room
because we know that he's going to turn
around and come back and start shouting
at one of them
more often than not but we have to work
with the world the way it is not the way
that we would have it be
and in that situation it it's going to
happen and i feel for the door staff
with this this is one of the things i
feel quite strongly about within the
nightlife industry that
they part of their job is to be a verbal
punching bag
um because this person has to do it
they are compelled to say this thing to
vent this anger to
do whatever the zeigarnik effect for the
people who know what that is this open
loop closed loop
system that we have there's an open loop
i haven't had my say i don't feel like
i've closed the door to hell
that is currently open in my mind about
the injustice that's just been caused
downstairs i need to
do my thing and even if it's just for
the person who requires being heard
that might be it that might but even
that person even the most
sedate person in the world let us say
you know one in 31 in 50
decides to just walk away um
even the ones like i say that are the
most collaborative that are the most
today out of those ones they still want
to turn around and say that they've been
hard done by
and of them some of them decide to walk
away once they feel like they've been
heard but that that open loop is
is a hell of a drug
yes yeah it is and it's and
the crazy thing about the negativity of
it in many cases until people
get the opportunity to feel heard
uh they feel even more self-righteous
about
having to express it
there's usually a lot of
self-righteousness in in in that anger
loop
i would agree um the converse of what we
said earlier on the most powerful
phrases
that we've got in negotiating are there
some that
people overuse or like some um
like a law uh artifact grandfathered in
old school tricks of the trade that
people think work during negotiating but
are just they just need to be thrown out
or this stuff that you see people using
a lot which just totally need to be
stopped
yeah well i i really the phrase win-win
bothers me
principally in the way that it's applied
not
the theory behind it but someone
someone who uses hey you know let's do a
win-win deal they tell me that right off
the bat
look i know you're trying to pick my
pocket and i just know you are
um if it comes out of your mouth in in
the first in the opening moments
because they sucker a lot of people with
that you know
win-win oh yeah cool yeah excellent
so p you know people get taken by that
or
somebody who comes in who's openly uh
you know they exude they want the
collaboration well they you know they're
they're they're a sucker for that person
you know that
that two and ten maybe that's that's
looking to just take them to the
cleaners
so i'm i'm always leery about the
utterance of the phrase win-win
and then you know are you trying to
shortcut the
situation like you don't know what a win
is because you don't know what i'm
holding back
i don't know what you're holding back so
any
one way that the other you're not trying
to get the best
collaboration out of this deal
if you're using those words
the thing that i really love about your
particular approach to communication
style in general is that it doesn't
require you to really remember
very much obviously you have to learn
the skills and
such forth but the intricacy anyone
knows if you've ever told
a little bit of a like a little white
lie and then the next week
someone comes and asks you about the
previous white lie
and then you you got to hold this like
meta
conscience in your mind and start to
construct all of the different ways that
that lie would interlink with the other
lie and
it's you know cliche it tumbles
snowballs into the
big gray lie that overtakes your life
but by
focusing on not even as you've said
they're not even playing the character
of someone
who has to be overtly about the win-win
i am here this is a collaborative
opportunity
but i still have things that i want i
have things that i want because that is
true you have things that you want
because that is also true
let us add our two truths together and
see where we can find a middle ground
yeah yeah or and i'm cautious that i'm
let's look for overlapping ground you
know versus middle
ground because middle ground that phrase
starts getting dangerously close to
compromise
and compromise is impossible for human
beings
because in 2002 danny kahneman
won the nobel prize in behavioral
economics for prospect theory
the short-hand version of that has lost
things twice as much as an equivalent
gain
so we distort loss in our head we
distort
our gives so let's say
i want 15 you want five
and we want to meet in the middle at 10.
well for both of us
that loss of 5 feels like a loss of 10
if you if you go with conor man's 2x
rule
and conor is actually given some
interviews where he indicates
that it's much more than 2x that he and
amos taversky said 2x
just to limit the amount of argument
i think i heard him say it's closer to 5
to 7x
which means you can never feel okay
in an equivalent nature to what you've
given in on until you've gotten the
other person back
for double what you gave up
so compromise always becomes a downward
spiral always
which is why it's to be avoided which is
why you want to get into a conversation
where
instead of compromise you're talking
about collaboration
where we come up with new opportunities
that neither one of us
envisioned or new possibilities that
takes us
at a loss entirely and therefore we're
not trying to pay each other back
i like that what are your opinions on
trump as a communicator if you were
coaching him what would you say that he
does well and what would you say that he
needs to improve on
see i'm a natural born assertive very
much you know trump and i are both from
the same
caveman tribe the assertive and
what the problem with assertives are
that
since we leave people feeling bruised
the people that are willing to deal with
this
become fewer and fewer and fewer and
fewer
you know you're you're you're fishing
out the reservoir
you know you're you're you're hunting
out the game
and a cruel classic example of what
happens in every one of these
is where where is
what is the status currently of the u.s
north korea negotiations
i'm not sure you're gonna have to tell
me that's exactly the point
nobody knows that's what happens
to the assertive negotiator negotiations
just start to slowly
fade they don't get concluded
the other side learns that when you when
they interact with you
that if they don't surrender that you
attack ah
that's interesting and there's there's i
if if i want to talk i'm gonna
if i don't surrender i'm gonna get
attacked and so what you
become conditioned to do is to stop
talking
entirely which means deals go away
and if you look at the history of
everyone that president trump has
interacted with since he's been
president
he showed up he starts calling names
again they start arguing
north korea doesn't surrender they want
they just they want to have a dialogue
before they surrender
he just wants surrender now where's the
negotiation
nobody knows every single person that i
ask
where are we on north korea everybody
goes
that's the response i'm glad that wasn't
a trick question
i mean i'd be i'd be happy to nobody
says we're in a great place
like if you're a donald trump supporter
you will not answer that question saying
what a great place
nobody says that yeah i think i i
i can really get a sense of what you
mean obviously donald trump isn't
directly negotiating with me but he is
uh secondarily negotiating with everyone
right
he wants when he is giving his speech he
is up on stage he is debating
joe biden he is having
a collaborative discussion where he
wants people to come onto his side of
the table he needs to put himself across
in a good way
and um i really do get that sense a
little bit that
four years ago the novelty of someone
who was gonna drain the swamp and kind
of didn't play by the rules and was
brash and forthcoming and like kind of
like like alpha masculine in
in a kind of a assertive hollywood
style president sort of way you know
like if denzel
if denzel was doing it there's like the
touches of that i think almost charisma
but after four years of never seeing
um the collaboration come through the
tarnish has been taken off the the shine
a little bit and it just
feels it feels a lot more brash than it
did previously does that make sense
yeah and there are a lot of people that
are going like yeah well i'm not a big
fan of government anyway
you know and and every few years in
american politics
an american businessman holds their hand
up and a massive amount of the country
goes like yeah we need a businessman in
charge
and what was it the 1990s ross perot put
his hand up and
instantly a huge portion of america was
like yeah we're tired of the
inefficiencies of government we're
willing to give a business man a shot
you know
everybody's disenchanted with government
and some of his approach
when he wasn't running the government
was yeah you could do work
but he can't say that anymore no you are
very right i mean
we keep on seeing this mike bloomberg
you know like i'll put my hand up i'll
have it i'll i'll
throw my hat in the ring so to speak
there is um
i kind of get it right because i think
people who maybe don't
do politics and don't do business
presume that someone who has spent a lot
of time in a boardroom
has some transferable skills maybe that
they can
kind of put across onto the other side
and i can utilize my business acumen
in a way that allows me and i don't know
like
there's certainly part like this middle
east thing that trump's done
is very very impressive and has kind of
been
pushed under the rug a little bit i
think i don't think it's been given
quite the media attention that it
deserved um but
by the same token i i'm not convinced
i i it's not for me to say that a career
politician is the best person to become
president but similarly i don't think
that this shows us
that someone who's coming from a
business background
happens to have some sort of competitive
advantage when it comes to
communicating or diplomacy or anything
else
i think that that ship's sailed a little
bit now
well i i can tell you from personal
experience you know having spent 27
years in
in a public sector you know the public
sector sees a private sector
and in a public sector we go like yeah i
could i could do that i could do that
over there and vice versa
private sector looks at the public
sector the government says yeah i could
do that
it has taken me every bit of 10 years
and we are still figuring out how to
operate effectively in a private sector
and principally because the majority of
my team
were never in a public sector but you
you
look over there and you say i could see
how i could do
better and
in the in the jet and moving from the
public sector to the private sector
there's no shortage of military generals
there were superstars in the military
that started consulting companies that
fell flat on their face
because they're they're two very
different animals
they look a lot alike you know maybe
maybe a zebra looks like a horse but a
zebra is not a horse
and until you've got enough experience
in either of the arenas you know you're
not going to realize how new you are to
it when you get in
private sector people say i run the
government on a better business
uh you know it needs to be more
efficient
some of what i was willing to see what
donald trump was going to do is because
i want to know how much is an inherent
problem in government and how much is an
inefficiency that just needs to be
gotten rid of
you know we've had that experiment a lot
more a lot more of it is inherent
i think it's a i think it is inbuilt
it's part of the source code
you know it's it's bootstrapped into um
the inevitability of any structure that
is just
so big and such a leviathan
um we have in the uk we have the nhs the
national health service and i have a
number of doctor friends
many of whom will be listening and they
constantly talk they still run on
windows 95
they're still faxing stuff like they
have to fax things
around and like mail post
there's no app there's no ipads that you
can walk around oh so what's this
patience thing it's
printed medical records it is such
a humongous beast that to try and enact
any sort of change
is essentially now untenable you can't
get change to occur and this is
something that should be considered
when talking any country the
grandiosity of potentially having
nationalized healthcare is that
when you if you're talking like truly
truly truly nationalized in a country
like yours of 330 million people
you are um
attaching everyone to the same flagpole
every single person
and if it starts to blow quite a strong
wind
all the flags are [ __ ] like they are
all all over the place they're getting
tangled up together
and then you've got to try and untie
them it is it's a real challenge so i
think
that's that's a side of the the nhs that
i think people don't see because it
still
functions at least from the outside
looking in you go in you get your health
care you kind of leave
but the knife edge that it operates on
like the closeness that almost
every patient is to their records being
lost or their appointment being
cancelled or whatever it is
it constantly feels like everyone's kind
of like road runner you know just moving
their legs as quickly as possible in a
desperate attempt to try and keep up
with the pace of what needs to be done i
think that's probably a consideration
for
for a lot of countries that are
considering nationalized healthcare
wow yeah yeah that makes a lot of sense
that's a that's a view the people that
are espousing
national healthcare uh don't want you to
see
no not at all so final question chris
you've been through a lot of very very
high pressure
situations i wondered if there was one
that comes to
mind that you could tell us a story
about and then also if that would be a
good
way to illustrate how you can deal with
pressure
there will be people who have a a job
interview
have the final negotiating negotiation
to keep their job
or to apply for a promotion or to get
the business deal or the merger or
whatever it might be
would that be able to illustrate how
they can perhaps cope with pleasure
pressure in a
high stakes situation yeah you know
really
uh the ability to uh articulate the
other side's point of view
in a way that they say that's right is
is the single biggest game changer you
know
their point of view when you express it
they'll say
that's right that's that's it exactly
you've got it exactly
that that's a game-changing move now
there's no negotiation approach that
works a thousand percent of the time
yeah i was i was coach i coached a guy
through a negotiation just a couple days
ago
and we weren't getting the person where
we want them to be and i said well look
i gotta tell you as a hostage negotiator
we were successful 93 of the time
that also meant that seven percent of
the time we had to shoot the guy
and our you know our success rate's 93
right and because this guy's trying to
negotiate as a vendor whether or not
he's going to give a refund of guys
demanding refund he doesn't deserve
and he wants to be nice about it he
doesn't he doesn't want to tell the guy
to just
you know f off and i said this may be a
guy you gotta shoot you know
this is a guy no matter what you can't
be nice to
because we were summarizing and
expressing the other guy's point of view
and i s and i said to him early on i
smell this guy is not going to come
across
he's he's not going to come out of his
position we can apply this but i don't
think he's coming out
so express the other side's point of
view
now there's two really good things about
that a significant number of deals
are going to make themselves in your
favor
once you get it that's right out of the
other side
the other thing is too is we found it
levels you
out everybody that takes the time
to thoughtfully be able to try to
express the other side's
perspective that
levels them out it takes them out of
anger
which then is also very good for you
because angers are poison
you know it's a poison you want to give
the person you want to poison but you're
the one that's actually taking a voice
and it just pollutes your system and
it's it's bad for you physically
insurance your life span there ain't
nothing good about anger
so trying to express the other side's
perspective in a way
where they say that's right we'll level
you out as well
now we had a negotiation kidnapping
negotiation in the philippines
the other side's got outrageous demands
i coach my guy
after about two or three months into
this look let's just get that's right
out of this
our bad guy because we were stalemated
and been stalemated for a while
so express his point of view tell him
that you know the philippines have been
ravaged for 500 years by colonial pounds
and the ransom that you're asking for
this hostage it's not a ransom it's for
war damage it's for economic harm over
500 years
and repeat back
all the other utter nonsense the
ridiculousness
of his justification because people
always over justified they always throw
in
every you know they you know your aunt
millie
wore the wrong socks you know they're
thinking of ridiculous stuff right
so just feed it back don't argue with
any of it just feed it back to him we're
gonna get her that's right out of him
the guy on the other side is a
sociopathic murder and rape and killer
he literally says that that's right when
we go into full
summer i don't know how long it took to
do the full summary but it took a while
it seemed excruciating on our end
terrorist sociopath on the other side
says
that's right immediately
the ransom demand went away we went from
10 million to zero when the phone hung
up
no monetary demand was ever raised again
through the course of the kidnapping
kidnapping last couple more months
the hostage walks away he gets the
opportunity they're lacking
in security he just walks away we're
flying back to the us
he's gone bad guys got nothing i'm back
in the philippines about three weeks
later
connect back up with the negotiator that
was coaching he says you're not going to
believe him call me on the phone
the terrorist what do you say
he said have you been promoted i was
going to kill the american
you're really good at what you do they
should promote you
which was a sign of respect which is
also him
saying i'd deal with you again
he was calling to tell him that he'd
deal with him again that they were okay
now not every negotiation gonna turn out
that well
but wherever summarizing the other side
leaves you is guaranteed
to be better than when before your
summary
and where that place gonna be i can't
guarantee i can only guarantee that you
will
always be better off if you take the
time to summarize the other side's
perspective
if only that it leveled you out and
that's why it's worth doing
chris i love that what an amazing story
today's been
just phenomenal so much for everyone to
take away if people want to check out
some more obviously never split the
difference will be linked on amazon in
the show notes below
where else should they go you know come
to the website
um blackswanltd.com
b-l-a-c-k-s-w-a-n-l-t-d
dot com we've got a massive amount of
free material
we got a a weekly newsletter that comes
out on negotiation tips and advice
it's concise which is even the most
it's it's complementary which means
there's no cost but better than that
it's concise and actionable plus the
newsletter happens to be the gateway to
all the other avenues on the website so
go to the website
newsletters listed as a blog in the
upper right hand corner sign
up you get the book and the newsletter a
lot of people start changing their lives
with those two tools
amazing man thank you today's been
today's been absolutely phenomenal it's
been 18 months
that we've been trying to schedule this
in and it was absolutely worth the wait
mate so i really appreciate you
having some of your time today thanks
for your persistence i have enjoyed the
conversation
[Music]
you